hey everyone welcome back to GameSpot it
is Wednesday Tuesday afternoon here in
San Francisco I'm Mike McCarty here with
Matt Grandstaff from Bethesda hey how
are you assisting community director
yeah sounds right awesome and we're here
on twitch YouTube GameSpot and periscope
I believe we are gonna be playing some
Skyrim VR and doom VFR Bethesda was
gracious enough to come into our studio
today and play it we've got Nick
margarita over here he's in the same
room with us he's gonna be playing these
games for us and kind of driving and
then now we've got Hey
starting with goofy a bar okay cool and
so yesterday during the Sony showcase
for like during the Paris games week you
got to show off Skyrim right we've been
showing at a so many events both Skyrim
bars clubs yeah awesome this is the
first time I believe Nick is playing in
the VR so well explain so why do you
want to notice how these games that we
might have already played have changed
yeah so walk through what's happening
here obviously so it definitely looks
very reminiscent to the doom game you
loved and played last year but VFR is a
new experience that also has some very
unique control mechanisms Nick is
playing with the PlayStation aim so all
the controls are on that if you if you
wanted to we could also use the Move
ones and if you was playing on on the by
which it's also coming to he'd be able
to use the vibe controllers okay so he's
teleporting around we've got 180 turns
he's controlling a grenade launcher with
his head tracking Oh left hand right
with well actually with the headset
itself it's on the left side oh right
and then with the the aim itself he is
controlling the gunplay launching
grenades cool and you got the pulse
rifle from the game we know in the other
hand right yeah yeah all the weapons
even weapon upgrades that you're used to
are in it you're not the do marine you
are actually if you play through doom
and actually if just play the beginning
of doom the elevator right before the
shot doesn't click doom title screen
yeah the guy that is dead in that
elevator is the guy that you are playing
now he is uh his consciousness has
then transported to an artificial brain
major top secret so this stuff that
we're seeing here taking place after
it's a sort of doom we're kind of during
it's kind of taking place during but but
if you can imagine that guy died before
the do Marine got there this could have
been anywhere in the Sun okay the demons
are not gone yet so right yeah also and
obviously like the glory kills were a
big deal from June 2016 right they give
you ammo or help so they can order to
drop help you would it would encourage
you to melee people in it to get a
Hillary charge you chainsaw people and
there's kind of that a nice game play
lose is that being carried over here yes
that's called tella fragging now and it
still has that bonus for you of being
able to give an animal health boost cool
and I hear you got a shield guy out yeah
so he did that perfectly right there he
teleported past him use the 180 term and
okay
so yeah I'm seeing like so you kind of
see him warping around like teleporting
using that that green line is yep free
Moscow red you gotta reapply it but oh
he's like kind of like jumping short
steps that's also an option so yeah I'm
the it would be the left hand of a move
controller or or alive but gear with the
aim there's actually a d-pad right by
the front of the gun that you can
basically deep had left right forward
back so he can kind of jump jump jump
ahead or move back so if a Cacodemons
shooting a fireball yeah they killed me
Mike yeah we have a death counter for
that or no no all right that was better
any my practice rounds though which is
good cool so like what is I am even
talking about like you link you can
expect from this in terms of the overall
playtime yeah I mean it's it's we've got
it on a pretty light difficulty setting
right here and Nick is died once already
that's okay Nick but we see most people
kind of getting through three to three
to five hours I guess
depending on how high you put the
difficulty up great that could be longer
gift starts getting to the point where
it's like one thing skills would you
move the difficulty all the way over
right
what about like collectibles it was
always fun kind of exploring the
environments is did you kind of have to
take some of those out or did the team
have to take some of those out to kind
of accommodate for just like purely
shooting and moving around we've got
some stuff in there like if you could
further enough in this level you know
you can find a little doom bobblehead
sit oh yeah I saw a few of those in they
have one of those in to evolve into and
a bunch it's right yeah I did fine
yeah it's interesting that team of all
games got moved into VR I mean obviously
it looks like it's still pretty fluid
but doom so much of it like the team has
talked extensively about it you know
like give up Martin and Marty Stratton
have talked about how they designed the
game focused on forward movement yep
apparently you know like enemies slow
down a little bit when you're not
looking at them to encourage that
forward movement but it's interesting to
see it going to be our and it looks like
the teleporting is kind of a solution to
that how do you keep yeah you're always
still moving with teleporting and and
the mechanic of you know slowing down
time it's similar to when you would play
2.16 there use the weapon wheel as a
strategy to kind of slow down and can
figure out your pathing but yeah for the
teleporting we feel like it's the best
mechanic or this yeah for going through
stuff but uh it still kind of applies
the principles of the main game game
sure and I'm so you said you can use the
Move controller like these or the aim
controller like he's doing right now or
you can usually use the Move wands is
there like a controller regular psvr
it's it's those two options and then the
vibe it's just these five sticks or
whatever we call those and like this
week this week you're showing a mainly
in PlayStation because of the S Paris
games week announcements every
yeah it's actually the first time in our
touring that we have been showing it on
PlayStation
we've been doing the vibe to date for do
I know there's a third one where is it
sometimes he runs away oh god Nick how's
it feeling from your perspective it
feels really really good
I like areas I found him
sorry we could talk later I like the
teleport teleporting beasts I can get
behind enemies and
quickly do a 180 and see if I can do it
is the 180 like map to an analogue or
something yes and so on the aim
controller there there's that like four
buttons on the right on the back of the
controller so it's just the very
something I also like the oh god I also
like that I can do kind of like a short
little percentage when I'm strafing
right here at the top trigger I can kind
of move like 30 degrees yeah there's a
left is right here stick but you can
flick right on them is that definitely
like reduces my sense of like nauseous
yes I guess just like you kind of have
to whittle down bigger enemies before
you glory kills and doing 2016 here the
same thing if you do before you do the
tell afraid right that's right okay and
that loop still exists like well
actually I was watching so when you tell
attract people you can get help okay in
2016 sometimes it would give you a
little of both or one or the other kind
of just balancing depending on what you
have very good for you I always love
that because when you're super low on
health it doesn't encourage you to go to
take hover and hide it actually says go
rip people apart don't end up the take
of things
good strategy the one thing that I will
say takes getting used to is that in
order to teleport I use my head and so
sometimes I forget and I just try to aim
Oh
we're using the aim for your right hand
gun I'm not taking oh what's that using
for your gun there we go that's a
grenade still to where we're in the
playthrough is this right now that we're
seeing kind of the middle I was gonna
say because he has all the guns are you
still like we've got my parademons and
yeah so this is a little bit early admit
game oh I've gone upgrades how are you
yeah so I'm old dancing with the right
button but uh as you go to upgrade
stations if you have the machine gun you
can I share two rockets or shop so we've
got upgrades kind of scattered
throughout the world
this is a good idea that's just not a
good idea
bad idea oh man oh man there's two hey I
did pretty good that time yeah you're
all right all right two deaths I'm
working on that no I'm just kidding you
did a good job with that
oh you're going on a transport station
right now all right
you still have the charge pistol shot
you can do I Philippe that's an upgrade
that's been around a first-century
he also has a button that he can stagger
them back okay so if it folks get too
close to you especially in VR if you
have three or four demons right in your
face you can press a button that they
kind of does a force push in all
directions and I've now called the
Khusro doom but yeah yeah you like I
enjoy good yep yeah speaking of for the
people just joining in on whether you're
on Twitter YouTube periscope or GameSpot
we are here playing doom VFR we got Nick
mere margarita using the aim controller
we're here with Matt grant staff from
Bethesda we're also about halfway
through maybe around 1:30 ish we're
gonna switch over to Skyrim VR to show
some exploring in that but right now
yeah oh yes I could kill right there
nice no matters that Telamon talking
about yep and it's interesting to see
like time slowed down and this reminds
me kind of what we might be I know we're
not talking about it right now but we
might be expecting with like the bats
and fallout we are yeah I mean just
touching on that with fallout 4 VR
that's is a little bit different in how
you you navigate you'll actually
activate it and whether you're
controlling with a direct movement or
teleporting once you go into vats it
goes into a teleport method regardless
of your controls and so I can cue up a
couple shots shoot the left arm shoot
for the head
and then actually teleport and use the
using action points as you're moving
through space and that comes out that's
goodbye last of our three VR games
coming out okay this year that's the
center yeah cuz you're saying it
Skyrim and then fall out and yeah yeah
we have a big Skyrim November 17 because
it's scattered ER and psvr and kind of
switch yeah that day and then doom is
December 1st for psvr and 5 you can also
play doom on switch on November 10th
cool a lot of days yeah yeah and then
next year at some point Wolfenstein 2
will be ported over to the which that's
awesome I just finished making I both
finished Wolfenstein is so good away
from me
the pulse rifle is an interesting choice
for that kind of I know it's like like
talking the community and everything we
have people who are fans of doom 2016 oh
no we use er what are some of the
questions that people were consistently
asking was it something like how do you
pour it such a like that fluid
fast-paced shooter yeah that's a big
part of it because what's countries they
doing 2016 yeah now but uh obviously you
would get into these large arena
situations yeah but like you said
earlier you're always moving forward but
but we feel like we've tackled a way
where you're always moving and still
getting into situations with hordes of
enemies but the control is is very
different it's also you know just for
anyone that plays a sense of scale when
you're playing this like attack a
diamond looks like the scariest thing
you could ever imagine I mean it looks
like you're looking at the most bloated
7-foot person ever
yeah it's scariest person ever to
obviously the using assets from you but
how much they look like how many of the
levels were redesigned to accommodate
our scrub through or did they take that
they just look at certain areas that
they needed to there's certain areas
that work the way they wanted it to work
for VR levels but at the same time we're
very cognizant of the fact that this is
the UAC facility and areas that you've
been in areas you were in previously
three that's three yes still doing good
though through that area I got further
than I did when we first practice in so
yep I'm proud yeah he's to an extent so
all these games are coming out would
launch so Skyrim and doom and fallout
will all be released simultaneously on
vibe as well with PS they are only a
couple of them do skyrim is PlayStation
VR only ok doom is vive and PlayStation
VR fallout is live only um it's a lot of
work for the teams to be going there and
getting these already and as we've told
our community and other folks we're
looking at XP or being an opportunity to
bring the games to other platforms other
PR platforms right yeah it's like I was
just creep in there like hey there come
through this door then nothing bad will
happen it's uh it's it's great to see
Bethesda you know and like besides not
just Bethesda but a lot of third-party
publishers and developers supporting its
which yeah obviously the Wii U hardware
was a little harder to to factor in when
you're talking about you know bringing
it from ps4 or Xbox one to switch is
different than you know like for any
things the Wii U the technology was not
exactly there but it's great to see the
switch doing well and I'm excited to try
out doom I know Nick played doom on
spokes a little bit a couple months ago
it's great to see Bethesda like working
with impend again I'm excited cuz I've
been playing my switch a lot yep both
played great I've played most more time
with Skyrim on switch but yeah both play
really well and you know from from the
day the switch came out the devs guys I
work with we're all we are all big fans
of what the platform is what it does
like we're traveling right now and we
can play Mario and talk about what we're
doing like in between taping stuff so
it's been great yeah you're travelling
kind of all over the country this week
right yeah yeah and so to have a game
like Mario honestly come out yeah right
in the middle of a pretty good deal and
and hopefully soon I'll have Skyrim and
doom on my switch as well hello
yeah yeah these are these are like super
it was it's interesting cuz you know
like III when because the first
announced fallout 4 officially they were
like oh it's coming out in six months
was it then that like officially
announced it right before release so
it's it seems like the Faysal likes to
do that right to finally show off stuff
not that long before its release so you
can like Pete there people's excitement
and then we get to play this yeah
it's a Never Say Never we might announce
something and then someday you know it
comes out a year or two later but but we
do like that idea of here's our 2017
lineup sure and we showed all these
different games at our showcase this
year and I don't think there's a single
one that you can't play in some capacity
at this point here or or by the end of
the year with the VR fibers right right
and it's interesting I mean like it's
one thing like I said like it just seems
so interesting to bring doom over to VR
for the reasons we talked about for the
shooter and like we talk more about this
when we start playing Skyrim but like
bringing that that massive open world
that a lot of us have been playing since
2012 when the game initially released
like it's gonna be so weird and
hopefully a big way seeing it in VR but
it just seems like such a daunting task
and I can't imagine the fun yeah I mean
it's the it's the first open-world
adventure in VR that is like you know
here's a big 200 hour game I say 200
hours but every time I meet somebody
they go room for 700 hours or something
like that's the introduction so it's a
big undertaking and you know the team's
been a really great job over the last
couple years and to be doing you know
for professor game studios to be doing
that with two VR type at the same time
you know let alone them working on other
projects like it's a huge age task for
them so do you know anything like behind
the scenes I'm not sure if you were
there early in the development but do
you know if it was it like was it but as
the approaching it or something and
saying hey we want to bring doom to VR
or is it vice versa or the kind of a
mutual interest in doing it I mean
there's always business discussions but
I can tell you just from about remember
it was three or four years ago when we
got a vibe set up in Bethesda Game
Studios and one of our devs actually
invited me out hey we have this now do
you wanna you want to check it out and I
had no idea whether they were doing
fallout for Skyrim or you know in in VR
so they just walked me through a very
early vibe demo where I think I was
inside an asteroid and breaking my way
out okay and the best part was there was
this really emergent raking moment where
all of a sudden I felt like this whets
insane
my hand and it was it was our lead level
designer for bgs Joel Burgess his dog
River who is you know the mocap dog in
the game right yeah he's in the room
with me while I hit the head got it I'm
licking my hand this is very like fourth
dimension kind of thing yeah you just
needed like some sort of smell to
complete it oh there's Bob there we got
a speaking of collectibles so we'll do
the gun pick this up oh is it this one
oh nice it done
you guys didn't expect me to get that
break in the game Nick doing it man how
about how long I mean we in terms of
like play we got like another 10 minutes
but when you're this build right now you
have this is the final build of the game
it's not the final bills but it has most
of the levels in it okay and I believe
it's leave it seven or eight chapters so
I mean he's only been in one of the
chapters this entire time yeah and so
here's an example of upgrading in the
game ammo okay so you can like increase
the speed or decrease the time at which
speed slows oh it looked like time
violation yeah so we have we have those
upgrades and then on top of that there's
also the actual the actual weapon
upgrades a little puzzle here some of
the cool stuff in VR puzzles that you
can navigate things where it's like you
know that condensation in VR or holding
the switch and pulling it forward or
pushing it great yeah and Matt you and I
don't have sound right now in the studio
but Nick and people watching you do is
like still like the metal music you come
to know I'm assuming Nick oh yes heavy
guitar riffs when you get into a fight
and that's that was one of the big I
should best joys of this game cuz the
same will seem composer did - yeah Nick
Gordon was on doom Wolfenstein he have
the USS the world tour yeah I was gonna
say they're lucky to have him I kind of
come into a few different properties
he's been he's been doing great work
I'm terrified
I know we've got the revenue no no no no
Nick I you seem to like the pulse rifle
is it it's because the boobs are so wide
and I can see them easily you know she
is so much bigger than I thought he was
yeah Oh what's he feel like about eight
feet or something I mean I'm not a tall
dude and he's physically like ten feet
tall you're playing as that person as
the do marine that you see dead on the
elevator are they a member of you are
you kind of in this like oh it's a
disembodied experience because you
actually when you start the game you
have these like little hands but you're
using yeah you you as you upgrade you
you give a soup to put on and start a
clipping weapons I was joking around
about doing it's probably the only
shooter I've ever played where I forgot
that I just always had a rocket launcher
yeah in any other game that's that's
like a super-powered weapon in this game
it's kind of oh I forgot I yeah once you
have it you have it and and but you also
have a ton of other insane guns like
when you get the automatic missile
launch or upgrade for the assault rifle
at least in doing point 16 that was kind
of constantly using it and that was one
of my favorite parts
you know experiencing the game is that a
lot yeah he didn't use the grenade
launcher
you know a lot of games you get to a
point where you feel like this is my jam
this gun of this guy yeah something like
that and doom with with the way the
balances with ammo like you're always
kind of saying nope I have to upgrade
everything yeah and start all I can
start switching between all of them and
they're kind of go yeah oh here we go
what do you want me to upgrade Mike um
I'm a fan of the super shotgun
personally okey-dokey there's a lot of
people out it's a classic what did that
just do do it I didn't see what what we
did
oh man I'd love that that's one of my
favorite shotguns in a game actually
speaking of gray that was pretty awesome
to finally get the shotgun or yeah
am I going dead I'm going with that okay
wait yeah Nick haven't used the grenade
launcher yet Oh
not really no I'd like to see that oh
they're just watching this makes me I
play Doom twice that thinks if he came
out I'll probably wait oh listen and
especially switch and VR whatever the
penultimate one was called oh okay I
don't not the hardest what's the hardest
one called is a chaos violence yeah yeah
I've not played that maybe I maybe I'll
do that maybe I'll ease into VR and then
do that the same difficulty levels in VR
I believe so yeah it's like it same
thing like I want to replay Wolfenstein
like with the separate Wolfenstein -
with a separate timeline between fergus
and Wyatt but I also kind of might want
to wait until the switch just to do that
but that's kind of who knows when that's
gonna be nice right which are you
playing this right now I did I finished
with the Wyatt timeline okay based on
all the trailers we want to do it more
cool is that the demo very nice Nik
margarita nice job you've done it three
dots or four three three do you think I
could do it there's three alright people
watching on twitch YouTube don't go
anywhere we right now we're gonna
transition over to Skyrim be our first
time we're showing a GameSpot delete
first time because it's livestream it
from an outlet outside of but what ABC
was earlier this year something yep so
stick around for that this is Matt grant
staff
Matt grant stuff sorry I just added a TV
Internet for both good assistant
community director for Bethesda unlike
my Hardy and Nick and another Matt from
the desert are setting up Skyrim VR so
we're gonna show you that meanwhile like
I said we just to reiterate release
dates for all these because you've got a
slew of games coming out right first off
we have Skyrim or sorry fallout 4 coming
to HCC uh
vs Skyrim VR the NBR PlayStation VR VR
that's November 17th
ok coincides with the switch release of
Skyrim cool same day doom VFR is
PlayStation VR and vive December 1st
okay
and then ends with fallout 4 on December
12th co-op I've only all the VR stuff
we're looking at what platforms we can
support next year additional ones and
then I think you are you tell me I'm
ready to go looks to every Skyrim all
right cool so Nick is using the
PlayStation Move controllers uh where
are you about is this like kind of tore
the beginning or this is this is after
you've escaped from Helgen okay say you
started the game this is actually where
we would present a lot of Skyrim demos
six years ago
okay I'm showing you off yeah everything
you can see you can go to those
mountains in the distance now you can
experience all the VR it's the game you
know and love it's you know doom was a
different experience from doom 2016 this
is Skyrim this is everything in Skyrim
and the world exists as we remember it
to in like a little bit reworked I'm
sure visually for ya I mean even if like
something subtle like if he twists his
arm and and moves the sword around like
you never were looking at the your
weapons kind of from all angles yeah if
you pull up magic now the ability to
kind of cast in any direction yeah you
want is is something that's I think
remarkable to do and play an experience
it just you kind of feel like you are
just amazing it was one of my first
character build in Skyrim and back in
2012 was kind of a spell in one hand
sword in the other kind of thing that
seemed super appealing yeah I would
always be flames and sword yeah or
restoration in flames yeah and and now
it's just like I just want to try
everything now with with the Move
controllers to go through this was
actually a like I kind of had a wild
moment when I was looking at this and VR
because just that the sense of scale you
get when you look up in the world the
skybox so yeah I think it's pretty great
feeling
so I forgot what someone back when the
game came out they timed how long it
took to walk from like the east end of
Skyrim to the West and I think it's like
40 minutes or maybe more I've heard
something like that yeah I just guess it
depends you know how much armor you've
got on you right yeah what your stamina
and I wonder if just like I mean I'm
sure in VR it just implies that sense of
scale so much more and kind of just like
you're the actual distance you're
traveling feels so much more you know
like yeah you do
you feel like you're you're really just
trekking through that yep next to all
the everything you want to be are stuff
this is a generated stream
okay and so before so this Michael is
going here do you need the Move
controllers or the vive wands so there's
there's three main controlled mechanics
we have the one that Nick's doing right
now is with the move and it with the
left move button pressing that in he can
then point in the direction he wants to
move okay so it gives a very smooth
movement with his right hand there I
think it's the X and O buttons he can
pivot the camera about 15 20 degrees to
really make sure he can direct himself
to where he needs to go obviously the
head tracking plays in the other move
Playstations much hold triangle on the
right hand for two seconds that'll
Crouch you to Lane in you blew it I know
yeah we have this on a novice right now
so if they go down pretty quickly don't
give yourself too much yeah
anybody else in the room you're clear of
Nick because he is flowing yeah so then
we have the teleportation controlled
mechanic okay and then if if you kind of
need a break he's standing up obviously
right now if you just kind of want to
experience Skyrim like you're used to
you can sit on the couch use a DualShock
and just use the headset for kind of the
immersive factor right Nick you've got
one headphone in but how does it sound
does it sound like you're in the cave it
right after I mean I played this game
three or four times and like a bunch of
different consoles this is so cool
because I've been here before
and I actually feel like I'm physically
inside what's yet for you actually
what's really cool if you go forward
because it looks like there's some light
passing through in the cake or maybe
that steam any any place like the the
first time you enter bleak falls Barrow
and then you kind of see the light
passing in or you're at the end of a
cave and you can see the light casting
out that you really have the sense of
like oh I'm actually here right that uh
bleep balls but for me was the moment
where I was kind of just stopped playing
Skyrim like I was playing Skyrim and
said I'm actually gonna look around sure
and see what the world looks like that I
can smell the roses exactly yeah Nick
when you're uh I'm assuming his
character has like fire ball or I can
equip that if you want whatever you want
I can't want to see the spells sure huh
okay so I want to it comes up as kind of
like a hovering Oh triangle or circle
actually on the left hand so that's your
favorites panel menu when you hit circle
it's just kind of Minority Report down
by holding the trigger with your left
hand two flames one more and then hit
the move button on both I like my hands
up on both hit circle and back out of
there and yeah so now you can you can
twist it turn your hands how everyone
and just start thinking apart I always
joke about it it's very cool yeah wait
point it yourself
where are these oh that's hot yeah that
is super weird to see because like I was
always the fixed point they were going
towards yeah yeah and so actually our
producer loaded me in a save without
telling me what I was about to see if
there was a dragon in front of me and a
pear and it was this oh crap moment
and like immediately I instinctively
kind of went like this and was passing
in one direction oh right I kind of do a
little word on how do you can down yeah
yeah you know just up the hands together
you got a donor echo
and actually so if you notice there when
he looks down that the quest compass is
now below an irrelevant information like
Health's a Manoa attica will be
displaying global commerce Jenny sort of
critical state they will raise up a
little higher on ascending so that
you're able to see it
gotcha and it likes a consolation page
where you're updating perks is that
still in tax the same thing yeah you go
through and you can hold the menu and
kind of cycle through everything the
maps actually really cool to pull up as
well you are kind of immersed in the
world probably at a thousand foot view
looking at the map and you can move
through with the same controller with
club Nick bring that up when he gets out
of the yeah there's a switch somewhere
that I don't know if you in it or not
someone's shooting there if you get a
two-handed weapon do you hold it kind of
differently I actually Nick once you
fill this guy I'll show you pick up that
longsword that's up on the turn around
real quick this is where I'm gonna make
Nick feel silly once you get rid of that
guy so you have a bow and arrow you
could you could pull out or you could
even probably get him with a game like
this burn slowly but surely he's head
back down towards the water
okay so this
and here yeah so kind of dip your toes
in it to the to the deep end of the pool
and actually Crouch physically don't
maybe it's not shallow enough but but
for swimming in the game you actually
when you go below sea level you can
Crouch and let's see better here you're
kind of at both levels of the wall and
if you're actually underwater far enough
just like the two shallow use the
triggers and you actually do kind of a
breaststroke Oh imma came up to swim
clear that maybe when we get outside
yeah let me go back outside Dino begun
that'd be kind of fun going over like if
you're doing a Thieves Guild mission and
you want to sneak yeah I I definitely
spent more time than I need to just kind
of like peeking my head out of the water
because it looks it looks really cool
when you do it an alligator yeah our
crocodile I think Marc machine but an
alligator works today
another thing that's awesome in my
perspective is that how the this sides
of the screen go dark when I'm like
sprinting or I'm moving around cuz that
helps me like if I'm feeling a little
weird you're like Weezy that that
tightness yeah II feel so much more
focused about what I'm doing yeah and
that's setting you know if somebody's
gonna walk doesn't like that there's
actually a slider that you can kind of
just how that works or turn off
completely if I jump in that River okay
so because of this river flow you'll
still need to swim it might be hard to
swim upstream oh yeah I was too tired
but yeah I look to the right and yeah so
you could just pop like as far as I
remember there isn't a point in Skyrim
where you can kind of get that both
levels where it feels up here I think so
like looking into this so cool and so if
you can get a little deeper yeah there's
some fish fishing as to if you can find
some deeper water where you feel like
you're not touching the ground anymore
once you're underneath you would pull
both triggers and do exactly what right
try to get try a turn around and try
going down the waterfall okay even if
you just have to walk to start with
think I'm walking yes whitewater rafting
that was great
that felt so cool when you get out of
the water Nick can we see the map yes
sir I'm driving dry off and uh is this
how I swim I think you're I don't know
if you're in deep enough water - okay so
the currents taking you under and at
this point you would want to make sure
your head is you know far enough below
the viewlet yeah now you're up you're
out you made it okay so to pull up the
map hi mr. right triangle on the left
hand cut your right hand and then you
know just press the trigger in and press
down to map yeah and so the same same
movement you were doing before applies
here so you're just kind of moving
through that beacon of light is actually
where you're presently at and I said all
Creek all right you're right by talking
but we have all the holds unlocked right
now obviously as you get you know
there's hundreds of locations in Skyrim
you know all of them are gonna pop up
here and you're gonna be able to to fast
travel as you need to throughout them
you can set markers just like you would
in the main game exams actually if you
as you can see right there we put a
little pointer and so that you can show
okay where in the world you're you're
looking to target can we go to so we can
go to a hold right now right here Nick
can you put it do you have it or no you
can't put your on your own together why
don't you get a white run it's right by
you yeah right there and then what do i
press to go there then you would press
the right move button okay so press the
right move button oh I got you click so
maybe not maybe we'll just adventure
getting it back I didn't kill that wolf
other critters need to find it where did
it go well there's this another good
place to be you could have to actually
walk towards up like falls too
you wanna see a larger scale combat and
cave what up this way
okay now and DoubleTap the move to run
left hand I think I am Rick I can't tell
I thank you hey you're moving pretty
quickly
yeah except you have right now empty I
don't know there's no third person no
third person that wouldn't really
requested a build a pretty sure he's
wearing the material yeah at the
beginning of the game and I know we have
that you know the iron armor she's seen
a dragon we all know excuse me ma'am hi
so you want to talk to me know that the
you could start the golden claw quest by
going in the house there or actually you
can just move around and you know ascend
to all the calls hello
alright so just keep going yeah yeah you
can go wherever you want but uh lady
your hearts can find out coming up this
way I would like to get a white run if I
could if that's cool if that's okay yeah
yeah if you want to nap on that that's I
don't work I was so gorgeous okay so
here oh also another question that maybe
you've been asked by the fans oh and I
will there be mod support at all for
this being on like there was with the
skyward special edition or anything
presently there's no mod support in the
game if it's something that we can
figure out as a possibility we'll let
everybody know but right now it's it's
everything that's in the base game plus
you know all the DLC cover okay oh yeah
what is that so the Dawnguard
I'm Tara matically all thumbs are hard
fire on fire and track Dragonborns the
one where you actually go to
so makes me happy just bringing back
memories next days it does I think
that's one of the cool things when you
when you play through this is it's like
wow this is all this I know all these
things but I never see ya at this before
and waiver I'm always reminded me of
that Arras from Lord of the Rings like
the Rohan kind of horselord area the
Companions quest line was was my
favorite of the kind of the side quest
stuff in the game yeah you first met
anybody because I started ear and double
dancin yeah got to the werewolf and all
that that's bumpy whoo yeah that was fun
what's that you get the shield at the
end right forget the guys name his
shield that you get from that tomb yeah
and then my favorite my favorite weapon
in the whole game is the two-handed axe
ya rabb that you got it cosplay house
player made one for me that's pretty
long that axe yeah it's badass era
you're firing on all cylinders a punset
making me look that I'm usually not that
good with them and all those things you
could have more kids and more puns have
yeah wow look at that
yeah nice little squ cup doesn't like
it's cool to me but wow there's a sense
of scale there yeah big time
here we go voting outside yeah even even
something like that like looking up and
seeing those archways like that really
you know what we're seeing right here
doesn't do it justice
yeah outside talk to the girl
my face thing oh you're good
facing the right way yeah for those
who's joining we got about another 10 or
15 minutes with Skyrim VR playing on
psvr whether you're going on twitch
YouTube GameSpot or Libra periscoping
this as well here with Matt Grandstaff
from Bethesda Nick margarita playing
over there
oh yes VR with the Move controllers he's
here in Whiterun people are suspicious
of him what did you do Loki backing away
they just make yourself put your hands
up you can actually or you can
fus-ro-dah her oh uh he just uses a move
control so yeah yeah he talked to the
girl it's just suspicious right now it's
understandable this guy with a with a
headset on with flashing lights walk in
the room if Nick margarita walk you
might be suspicious he's got that look
about yes you are all girl all girls
everything
yes sir I did so sorry saying oh yeah
yeah we uh Matt and I don't have audio
walking all right we can imagine yeah
Nick's making the sarcastic song kinda
looks like it needs want to do I'm gonna
leave see ya
check you later talking and now Oh
something funny you could do you can
leave them with uh you do have your
we've unlocked the dragon shout so why
don't you just mess up their tour yeah
just the table not them right you can do
it but if you just want to knock the
table over oh wait wait for to recharge
on that Oh luckily he went to the play
setting that didn't get anything October
so he's not pissed hey hey what say yet
oh wait yeah it's got a recharge I will
teach something outside that guy's
spared for today yeah huh you're sparing
that guy for now did some of the
community that's I'm flying so yeah
you're getting that black ring around
the division when you're kind of - as is
you're doing direct movement yeah thank
you whoa I just felt like like a sense
of fear of heights no Heights yeah hey
no sir
I think it's now wanted do not move
[ __ ] going down the renegade roof with
this character get out here
oh god there are many of them oh sweet
your life your your leveling up as you
as you would right in my face probably
give them a shout oh it's not the
limited shout them oh yeah you got a
hold it hold it longer to get there go
this right you are surrounded dumb or
done we're bailing you can't even hear
us making fun
are you making fun of me for it all
night useful we're talking about
something like that
yeah this week yeah another good one is
the electric sparks yes the master level
destruction spells are awesome this is
the cheapest do this in the game and now
it'll be like standing here whoa there's
a lot of them this is it this was always
the thing and we do have it on a fairly
easy level difficulty got the healing
spell - you'll never get me yeah you do
have restoration if you need it I'm
bailing never coming back to this
community ever you know you know that
that's gonna happen this map shows game
shows you know check this out yeah they
pick out of the card right away in the
card usually is overpowered and they
just dead in a couple minutes because
you can never really do there's no
thread right there nice that was
convenient
you never account for what Nick
margaritas gonna do he's kind of just a
rogue guard
can't really sends through him you're
getting a lot of experience that is an
awful lot of guards right there
we got a triangle triangle triangle
button left hand I'm gonna try to turn
around do it you're gonna die yeah you
are done I got me oh man the family way
to go down Nick there are a lot of
guards there yeah yeah why is your my
defense you you uh you broke the law
look but now I get to play with the
sword here yep do your little twisty
twisty of the sword sorry I died so
that's one death for Scott oh yeah we
got three deaths for doing one for
Skyrim probably one guy as much of this
out assumes you just keep killing
innocent you think it's six more
everybody gets it free now we're good I
guess
perfect I wanted to be five yes we do
not have pizza to give you I mean we do
but we do
Nichkhun you Rifton I always liked
rifting a lot know if you can me uh
quickly no never mind just do your
things if you go after after the deer oh
hey oh wait do your pelts happy
Halloween
Nick it's just a terror what this is you
gotta let the people see their no over
here no combat it's all about since
since you have the deer there you might
actually want to check out the bone
arrow as your oh yes killing all the
game out there in the wild
um mmm my items yes mm-hmm
yep go down weapons and all the way to
the bottom you should see longbow just
kind of keep going
yep oh I don't know if you got it there
and just press one of the move buttons
back out with circle we went through
this before but basically you hold them
both up kind of parallel to each other
maybe like this
you use the trick you can't see what I'm
doing but you knock it back and yeah you
love it pretty not toward an innocent
person there was nothing there I know
what is that that is a butterfly there
is no chance I hit the butterfly we're
not giving you free pizza hundred
dollars where you go he's on the post I
think I was playing yesterday and I cut
the butterfly down with a sword and then
because it picked it up and then was
just throwing the butterfly down the
hill I never things you can do there's
some wolves around here we'll do a
little wolf hunting
yes the Guardian stones so this guy's
down down below just past those stones
so down there yeah
no just jump off that cliff yeah there's
a little campsite over there see it off
yonder right there or there right here
dead ahead
oh so you can go sneak so hold triangle
to get into your sneakiness board let
them know you're coming with a well time
[ __ ] there you go okay somebody I don't
know what you were aiming for a headshot
okay I get a sneak damage bonus damage
right looks pretty good there oh nice
Oh gonna take more than that it's gonna
take some practice right cuz there's not
an actual crosshair at least we're not
seeing yeah you really want to look down
the side of like the tip of the arrow
and look at the angle and that's what
everything you know we're training
training you to be oh yeah a real hunter
I like it's more kinda actual kind of
something you could practice yeah I mean
it's something to wear I've seen some of
them pick it up I don't know if they
asked if they were an archery Andrew
sharp who's the lead producer on the
game don't is a excellent Archer has
taught me well oh wait sorry like in
real life no no no actual in Skyrim
okay that's what you're good oh wow took
an arrow to the something else yeah so
want to wrap up now right around now are
you want to go a few more minutes or
where any questions you have or or Nick
Nick turn your left you're facing the
blue screen right now
oh sorry come back we've got maybe
another few minutes
Nick what do you want to do whatever you
would like I can
and look at a nice Vista and you're also
crouched right now so if you hit
triangle and law are there we can get
again he's wandering Wiseman slow hit by
a giant yeah you can go find a giant
they're out right through the air the
farmland south away run uh okay that boy
just go that was John Luke from the back
room what do you say John Liu quite a
giant if you get hit by a giant it
launches you in the air with the physics
oh okay let me just hit this moose Oh
God
if he gets around this wall you're
getting good with the bow
that was excellent that's true yo what
up okay okay yeah there's no stables
right by the way yeah right so no uh
yeah there you go you're just south of
there that's where you meet the
companion speaking of right if you fight
the Giants or you can meet them there I
don't want to get hit right in their
little Hut
oh but you know you're right you think
you'd meet them and they say come over
this way
come yonder I'm saying yonder would I
yeah show Skyrim when in Rome I think
they kind of they usually have a
sarcastic remark like you could hone
your fighting skills more you want to
come to their help us out or something
yeah like oh are the Giants like over
there south way around I thought yeah
south southeast maybe this way right
I thought there were a tower no there
wasn't me right there's there's
definitely one and I guess it depends on
you know your character level in some
cases of where things appear but there
used to be one big garden if I recall
its East very sorry West you go west uh
I think you're going right way okay I
think
I don't want to do this I don't want to
get hit hope you go clients here maybe
not this time I think part of it might
also factor in could be wrong but might
factor into what you've done in the
questing yet like we haven't even done
bleep falls yet so what's your left
regular dude your left yeah he's up on
the rock that's just the way run garden
it was as we all know her still not safe
from Nick hi how are you
that cat's-eye that's actually something
I was think I was at answering a reddit
question or something or somebody was
clarifying a an interview I did and they
said that I implied that we have added a
virtual waving out of the game and
technically it's true like you can take
your flame hand to just you know hey
what's up you can't you might
accidentally be like someone fire but
you might happen yeah well not seeing
any Giants boys I apologize right
another time that you are a giant among
men you've done great let's just stand
on this hill and ponder existence I
ponder your distance all the time ah
cool all right so much beauty Nick
thanks for walking us through Skyrim VR
yeah and Matt Grandstaff thank you so
much one more time I'm gonna ask you
what's this feel like these three games
sorry these two and fallout when can we
play in what platforms pretty soon but
walk us through it sure so November 17th
so what that's two weeks away
we've got Skyrim VR on PlayStation VR
also happens to be the same day as
Skyrim switch which is that's a motion
controls to it but yeah if you are
obviously doomed VFR is December first
and then and that's PlayStation VR and
vibe and then vive only fallout for VR
on December 12th you're on other
platforms wondering about your VR we're
looking into that stuff in 2018 as the
time when we'll be talking about other
other
cool so Bethesda's got a busy end of the
year coming up for VR for switch for a
few different platforms some very busy
yes then what next year we're gonna get
some Wolfenstein - at some point you
haven't played that yet go play that but
again mad thank you so much joining Nick
thanks for playing Bethesda thank you so
much for coming in to show us these
games you know you've had a busy week
bill the Paris game show stuff going on
or at least the Sony showcase yeah San
Francisco if you join on Twitch YouTube
GameSpot or if you're on periscope
thanks so much for joining well we'll
have videos up throughout the week I'll
probably break these videos out if you
didn't get a chance to watch the whole
thing you can go back and watch Nick die
a few times doom what once in Skyrim
wasn't that bad exercise as always thank
you so much for joining we'll have
another live stream at 11 a.m. Pacific
tomorrow that's the lobby our live show
so as always stay tuned for that and
then for more new views features stay
tuned and games bye and we'll see you
around thank you
[Music]